así que está muy buenos días raúl pues
lo cierto es que la mayoría de los
proyectos de ley van a necesitar el
respaldo de al menos 60 votos para poder
llevar a cabo esa votación y esa
aprobación de manera que se van a quedar
van a tu lugar de alguna manera los
planes más ambiciosos de joe biden y de
los progresistas sí que es cierto que
hay algunas medidas como las de cuestión
fiscal que sólo necesita una mayoría
simple 50 +1 que en estos momentos los
demócratas
han conseguido por ejemplo esas
políticas para hacer frente a la crisis
económica del coronavirus a través de
esos estímulos financieros se podrían
aprobar sin embargo hay una creciente
ola de senadores que están pidiendo
eliminar esa
y esa norma que requeriría los 60 votos
en la cámara alta y se podría debatir en
los próximos meses desde elegís la
altura de hecho el cuando se necesitan
esos 60 votos van a requerir que el ala
más moderada del partido republicano se
ponga en la mesa y aborde junto a los
demócratas algunos de los temas que se
quieren tratar por ejemplo ya mitt
romney el senador republicano porque
está ya se han mostrado ha dispuesto a
hablar con los demócratas para poder
llevar a cabo parte de la agenda
propuesta por el nuevo gobierno de joe
biden antonio ahora como se puede
explicar el hecho histórico que quiero
en georgia al elegir senadores
demócratas
cuando se celebraba la segunda vuelta si
ambas campañas se preparaban durante la
campaña electoral sabían que iba a ser
un resultado muy ajustado y había la
necesidad de enfocarse en las minorías
la estrategia del partido demócrata que
al final le ha salido bien fue centrarse
en las minorías en las la población
afroamericana y los latinos que en el
mes de noviembre no fueron a votar y que
ahora sí que lo han hecho viendo el
panorama actual en estados unidos eso
mayormente en las grandes urbes como
aquí en la ciudad de atlanta y como pasa
en la mayor parte de estados unidos la
tendencia suele ser el demócrata pero en
las zonas rurales suele ser más
republicana de hecho ese fue el fija
miento que se marcó el partido demócrata
enfocarse en las minorías sobre todo en
estas zonas rula rurales y de esa manera
pudo conseguir el voto